[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
merci
un bon là
des secousses au monde ont navarro 6
oh
alors ça fait du bien de sortir
et merci à beaucoup d'entre nous ont
passé une année
enfermés dans notre petite bulle
beaucoup l'an passé en étant isolées et
d'autres confrontés à la souffrance à l'
angoisse la douleur la peur mortels et
nous voilà enfin après un an sans pareil
réunis dans les jolies fringues et ça
vous a manqué un petit peu plus glamour
1 un petit peu ouais pas moi aussi mais
vous inquiétez pas parce que dans deux
heures je serai de nouveau planté devant
les caméras dans mes pyjama en train de
regarder la télé le cinéma ou bien même
je sais pas france italie côte est alors
les légendes couturier vous faites des
des robes magnifiques mais il n'y a rien
de mieux que de passer une soirée en
jogging en train de ryanair les films
pendant cette année de transition
le cinéma a été ma bouée de sauvetage et
j'ai redécouvert les films de kurosawa
de scorsese de banjo niveau de pedro
almodovar de lina wertmüller et aussi de
monsieur le président spike lee
nice a été fermé oui mais le cinéma
continuer malgré d'édifices toriques le
cinéma continue sous des formes
nouvelles toujours
alors après 55 ans de métier j'apprécie
l'évolution de l'art l'évolution
constante la créativité qui se
renouvellent qui renouvelle notre métier
et je veux surtout m'inspirer de
nouvelles voies passionné par le cinéma
cette énergie va tous nous faire
redécouvrir la magie des images
l'authenticité des émotions
le bouleversement la provocation qui se
libèrent de nouvelles et c'est comme ça
que nous nous retrouverons le cinéma est
là pour ça pour toucher pour connecter
pour transformer et après après toutes
ces années de métier ça me fait toujours
un petit frisson s'ouvrir et de se
donner vos spectateurs m'apporte la plus
grande joie et je me perds vrai je ne
perdrai jamais les mêmes
l'émerveillement et la gratitude pour le
cinéma alors merci beaucoup
[Applaudissements]